Because of the explosive popularity of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, people are more
aware than ever of the weirder characters
from the comic canon.
However, there are a few heroes that will
likely remain on the bench no matter how big
the MCU gets: heroes like Moon Knight.
Depending on who's writing him, he's either
a Batman knockoff or a killer who talks to
a moon god — when he's not already busy
talking to his multiple personalities.
Despite being so strange, Moon Knight still
has a cult following, and his fans have clamored
for years to see him appear on the silver
screen alongside Captain America and the gang.
But, despite the fan love, it's a pretty safe
bet that Marvel won't make a Moon Knight movie.
Here’s why...
Risky religion
When it comes to religion, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has treaded pretty lightly, outside
of Captain America’s take on having a bunch
of Norse gods pop up.
"There’s only one god ma'am, and I’m pretty
sure he doesn’t dress like that."
But with Moon Knight, it's impossible to separate
the man and his religion, such as it is.
He draws his powers from the Egyptian moon
god Khonshu, so pretty much any version of
his superhero story would mean introducing
a whole new buncha gods to the MCU.
We already have Asgardians.
Go any deeper, and this world gets a whole
lot more confusing.
So, as the story goes, Moon Knight is the
moon god’s chosen one, and becomes a vigilante
to do Khonshu's bidding, which sometimes actually
includes murdering the bad guys.
In case you were wondering, none of this would
really translate to Marvel's cinematic universe
too well.
Unless it’s handled perfectly, it’s easy
for Moon Knight to come across as little more
than a murderous, crazy cult-member.
Think less Daredevil, more Zodiac Killer.
That's not gonna sell too many action figures.
Redundant
One key area where Marvel has been successful
is making its various onscreen characters
seem distinct.
It takes a mix of great casting and making
the right story decisions, and for the most
part, Marvel is killing it.
Robert Downey Jr. set the bar pretty high
with Tony Stark, and they were careful enough
with Doctor Strange to make sure he didn’t
just hit the same rich, white guy hero beats.
But when it comes to Moon Knight, he falls
into a whole lot of Batman's territory — and
in case you haven't noticed, Batman's got
a lot of territory.
Let's see: rich guy, a mask-wearing vigilante
by night, lives in a mansion built over a
cave, is assisted by a faithful butler, and
uses themed weaponry to take out bad guys.
Sound familiar?
Yes, Moon Knight is obviously more than just
that and has several differences when more
closely compared to Batman.
But he checks a whole lot of the same boxes
as the Dark Knight.
For the average movie-going audience, it’d
probably be a few boxes too many.
Now, while we're on the subject of being like
Batman...
Too gimmicky
Batman uses a whole lot of gear and gimmicks.
But imagine if all those Bat-arangs were now,
umm, moon-arangs?
Is it getting cheesy yet?
Viewers have had decades to get used to Batman's
brand of Bat-themed justice, but it might
be hard to spring an entire moon-gear line-up
on them at once.
Heroes typically have a signature weapon that
makes them stand out — think Iron Man’s
armor, or Captain America’s shield.
But Moon Knight doesn’t really have that.
One look at the guy in action and all audiences
can really tell is that he's kind of all over
the place.
Mental health
Mental illness is a delicate subject in general,
and it gets even dicier when it comes to superheroes.
After all, anyone who puts on spandex and
spends their nights punching people must have
more than a few screws loose, right?
"Oh no, I’m just standing around, ya know.
Huh!
No I’m not!
Ahh!"
However, Moon Knight is established as literally
not sane in the comics on multiple occasions.
That could be tough to bring to life on the
big screen in a respectful way.
A major part of Moon Knight's madness is his
multiple personalities.
The roster ranges from taxi driver Jake Lockley,
mercenary Marc Spector, and even other superheroes
like Spider-Man, Wolverine, and Captain America.
At times, they all interact in Moon Knight’s
head, which would not be easy to portray in
live action.
Unfortunately, if moviegoers aren't ready
for a super-violent religious zealot for a
hero, they're definitely not ready for an
outright unhinged one.
That outfit
Let's be honest: Moon Knight's costume would
be one of the toughest to make look cool on
the big screen.
It's true that most superhero costumes look
at least a little goofy in their original
comics.
But the tried and true ways of fixing that
in a movie wouldn’t work here.
The typical move is to make it leather, and
make it darker.
For instance, Scarlet Witch's bright red spandex
became a maroon jacket and black pants, while
Hawkeye's purple get-up morphed into a nearly
all-black outfit on film.
But Moon Knight’s costume is white.
Like, all white.
If they made it darker, it wouldn’t be Moon
Knight, and after a few bloody fights, that
all-white costume would start to look pretty
rough.
Realistically, he’d spend most of the movie
looking like a super-hobo once the action
started.
Better on TV
It's been rumored for the better part of a
decade that a Moon Knight TV show could happen.
Though we’d love to see him get a shot at
big screen glory, it’s obvious the character
would be better served on the boob tube.
Having an entire season to develop his character
— all of them— would allow audiences to
digest the complexities of all his different
personas.
Put simply, it’d take a TV season to provide
the breathing room for the villains, the supporting
cast, and world-building necessary to make
Moon Knight work.
His character seems tailor-made for Netflix,
which already features Marvel anti-heroes
tortured by guilt, loss, and trauma.
Then, if Moon Knight doesn't end up fitting
in with Jessica Jones and Luke Cage at first,
he can just keep swapping personalities until
he does.
Problem solved!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!